good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters Oh
Hank I only got like an hour to make
this video so I got to do it a little
bit brotherhood dew point Oh style you
know the edits won't be that good I
won't talk that fast to keep the
audience entertained many explicable
champagne poppers better of my ears
hey I've got two problems first I've got
to get ready to go to LeakyCon and then
immediately after we ki come and I got
to go to Australia and secondly I got a
ton of work to do on the edits of the
book I'm writing with David Levithan
generally Hank when my floor looks like
this it either means that I'm in an
editorial panic or that Willy has broken
into my office but ain't none of that is
going to keep me from answering
nerdfighter questions are you more of a
Spock or Kirk fan there's a reason that
this is the symbol for nerdfighteria I
can't do the nerdfighter hand sign give
a workaround yes a workaround was
invented by our secret niece and nephew
Natalie and Calvin in Australia who I'm
going to be meeting soon if you can't do
this you can just do this do conjoined
twins get two different social security
numbers yes each conjoined twin gets his
or her own social security number why
are there so many blank pages at the
back of the hardcover of Looking for
Alaska here's an interesting fact when
you print a book the number of pages has
to be a multiple of eight and if it's
not a multiple of eight they have to
include after pages so it becomes a
multiple of eight but I prefer to think
that it's so that you can write little
notes to me at the end extolling my
brilliance can I have what's in the
basket behind you the only thing that's
in the wicker basket behind me is the
responsibility of separating my books
about Islam from my books about
Christianity you want that
responsibility no offense but the wicker
basket is doing a fantastic job
why would I replace it with a human
being what was your first job my first
job was working at a warehouse filling
semi trucks with boxes of stereo
equipment it was actually exactly like
Tetris except you had to play in
110-degree heat and all the tetris
pieces weighed 30 pounds
would you ever release your ongoing
story this is not Tom to the public it's
already available to the public for free
each week on the Internet if you're
asking if I'm going to publish it as a
book then no why do the same books have
different covers in different countries
they don't always but because my
publisher is different in each country
they get to design their own cover how
many digits of pi can you recite from
memory 3.141592 hey what's the seventh
digit of pi yes does bubbles the
nerdfighting puppy have any magical
powers
Willy give any magical powers oh my god
how do you do that okay I have to go
find my magically disappearing dog but
I'll see you singing tomorrow and in
real life
in a couple days we call this move the
deceased rabbit